[Music]
all right let's go to tracy in
louisville kentucky tracy how can we
help
hey thank you so much for taking my call
you bet um so
my husband is a combat veteran who's
been diagnosed with ptsd and
schizoaffective disorder
and the longer that he has been out of
the service
the more difficult it is for us to
communicate
and be on the same page um
especially when it comes to our finances
um
hang on a second take a breath take a
breath take a breath take a breath take
a breath
workout just sitting in my car my
heart's beating so fast bless your heart
you're good we're here with you take
your time
how long have you been sitting on this
diagnosis
since 2016.
can i say the obvious out loud
it is hard to
love somebody and live with somebody
who's get to effective disorder right
yeah
you might still love him of course you
do you love him to the end of time
but you've been through hell the last
few years haven't you
yeah yeah and he's
he's contemplating divorce yeah yep
and there's probably a part of him that
deep down in his soul thinks that your
life would be better without him am i
right
yeah because he's also very um
he's almost taken his life twice too
that's right yeah that feeling of
burdensome
of burden oh i'm sorry so so sorry what
a mess
what's his care regimen look like
um
right now like
uh he's not on medications we tried that
route
and um the va just basically threw pills
at him and the side effects were worse
off than dealing with it without
medication
um he was meeting with our pastor for
for counseling and our pastor is not a
licensed therapist but more of like a
companion yeah um he needs some true
trauma counseling in a um
he's gonna have to get a doctor and a
psychiatrist that'll walk alongside him
it's not just gonna throw pills at him
but this is a tough tough road to hoe
is is he giving up hope
i don't think so no he's still here
yeah yeah
oh man um yeah this is i mean you know
this and this isn't why you called but
um
this would fall into a very limited
number of situations in my world that
would be a red a red alert situation i'm
going to call not the va i'm going to
get the money i'm going to figure the
finance part out but we're going to sit
with a psychiatrist to our medical
doctor that we trust and it will um
that somebody recommends that this will
listen to you and we'll start small and
build up the right way and
get into some trauma counseling asap
what i want to tell you is i know folks
in that situation and there is help on
the other side of it
it feels like
everybody's drowning on this side of it
i'm so sorry you're going through that
do you all handle your finances together
are you the primary person who handles
it what's that look like
i'm actually a randy preferred coach
um
it's more along the lines of um i do the
budget and include him in it
um
and
he sees money differently than i do
because of the
near-death experiences that he's had
that money to him is just
it's not
tied to a tangible feature i guess would
be a way of describing it like he
doesn't view it the same way
that i do or somebody with the sound of
mine does
it's it's just another thing essentially
is the way he described it
well he's he's seen
he's got a very tangible he's breathed
the air of there's not going to be a
tomorrow
and so it's really easy to fall into
since there's not going to be tomorrow
let's live it up today let's spend
everything right
yeah yeah
and again whenever you've got a brain
that all ptsd is your body responding in
the present as though the trauma you
experienced in the past is happening now
and what a good trauma counselor do and
by the way um there's a number of
programs and study there's so many
different routes these days that they
didn't have five years ago 10 years ago
15 years ago there's some really
extraordinary stuff on the horizon i'm
not in the horizon it's already here um
man when you get your body to calm down
in the present then the future looks
real and right now the future's just not
real it's it's a myth right
and you know that you live in that
um
is he accumulating debt or just spending
all the money that's coming yeah it's
just a hole in the checkbook what what
is it
um
so he's accumulating a little bit of
debt
my name's not on any of it except for
the house
um we have like our joint savings he's
got his own credit card that he's slowly
accumulating debt on and then
um
does he know this is a problem or is
there a philosophical issue here
he knows that it's a problem for me okay
would he honor you enough to give away
the credit card like when i work with
folks with bipolar one of the things is
you got to put some roadblocks in front
of you right i know that things get
harder than your manager when you're low
but you got to put some roadblocks in
front of you is he willing to do that or
no
no he's not okay
we've had that conversation and
um he's at this time now okay
so here's where
things get hard and i want to give you
two pieces of wisdom here okay number
one i want you to let the shame
that you're a ramsay preferred coach and
you're married to someone who's
struggling let that go yeah you're not
failing anybody okay
you're carrying this thing around that
you should be this because you're
licensed i mean you're certified as that
man you are in
hell
both of you are and it's hard okay we're
walking with you we're not putting our
fingers at you okay will you release
that shame to set it down
yes thank you okay and the second thing
here is
you
and you alone need to go see somebody
and i say you alone your husband clearly
needs to go but you can't make that you
can't force that you can't will that
and you got a guidance
go ahead
i am seeing our church counselor i want
you to go to my therapist i want you to
go see a trauma therapist you've been
married to somebody with ptsd and
schizoaffective disorder if that's even
a true diagnosis
and um
you need to go see somebody because
you've had whether it's secondary trauma
or true trauma you've seen it all and
you've experienced it all and you've
woke up in the middle of the night next
to somebody who's screaming and who's
sweating and who's bleeding you've been
there too now
i want you to go see a trauma therapist
somebody knows what they're doing who's
licensed and who will walk alongside you
it's not going to be as hard as you
think it is but it's something that
you've got to do for you
[Music]
thank you for your service we love you
we love you we love you keep us in the
loop if we keep walking alongside you
we're here for you tracy don't give up
you have so much value
don't give up
do not give up